[Music]  so this year we're aiming to remove 40  000  um guards from the from the landscape  working with partners like like tubex to  make sure that they're recycled  correctly  i think for us it's important that it's  uh  to note that there's a community effort  to renew guards  we will bring a group out from kind of  an urban area of leeds or blackburn or  bradford and actually come out and spend  the day spend the day in the dales you  know asylum seekers and refugees who you  have to kind of get away from the  stresses of their lives  we've got one that's uh that sheep's  wool which uh you know everybody  especially in the girls  big farming community is getting quite  excited about we've got a couple of  classes we've got traditional um  cardboard tubes as well in various  heights  compostable  plastics as well which need to be  composted at 50 degrees centigrade  [Music]  you